30 34.6 of cheating females and
25.25.9 of Qi in males did so because
they were bored with their sex life
there we go
really friendly
one more time
but I'm saying I'm gonna have the good
man at home that's not bump but then I
want to be in my family he becomes a sad
man because that's my husband so who's
fulfilling you sexually my pucks man I'm
the question was the man is dry in bed
he's rubbish I'm clearly bored sexually
right so are you Justified I'm not
justified
your orgasm doesn't matter as a girl oh
yeah true let me see it doesn't it no
I'm seriously you can't have everything
like y'all what you what you want you
want to go with a good job you want you
want a guy with a good job yeah that's
that's taller than you I know that that
but you're higher taller I don't want
this oh he can ever she's in general in
general okay in general to a good job
right you want them to be good looking
you want to be attracted to be attracted
to him okay and and you want him to be
taller than you right no I want him to
be my preferably my height but I've
dated small numbers okay okay within it
okay
okay let's take the height let's take
the height off
you want him to be attractive yes you
want him to have a good job yeah you
want him to be a stepdad
um yeah yeah you have children and you
want him okay one at a time oh okay
sorry I don't know and you want him to
rock your world in bed I could rock you
or and if and if not and if not no no no
no no no no no no no no you can't come
on man let's not let's not go into the
business of changing men they are who
they are so
so okay okay
so let me
and you also want him to be good in bed
and if he's not you're going to cheat
with the post guy
the disrespect
file you might as well ask him file a
partridge in a pear tree
whatever it is else you want because
what you're looking for is
doing my duty I'm laying there being
bored for after 20 years yeah but your
duties
sorrow on some level if you can't be
loyal then luckily this is just a
question and that would be because I'm
settling
you realize this sounds like this this
sounds like delusional people
hang on one second lady I remember there
used to be this this whole phenomenon of
wifey material yeah I don't know if it
went outside the UK but it was laughing
we all grew up we all know it yeah all
the girls claim to be wifey material and
all the man then we're looking for a
girl who is wifey material we all know
that right right point I need to make
very clear on this platform today here
is that within I hope you understand
right that
I'm not a
[ __ ] does not equal I am wifey material
whereas when women say I'm not I'm they
go uh well I'm not I'm not a slapper of
course I'll have to nah Bridget doesn't
mean just doesn't mean you're loose You
Can Be You Can Be You you don't have to
be Lucy there's a lot of things you
don't have to be you still ate in
between her because men don't hear wife
if men don't hear wife how's your wife a
material can I ask a question you cannot
someone could answer this one first of
all if men don't hear wife how is that
wifey materials they're gonna have to
listen hear that I mean answer that
right
um they're gonna look at during the
dating process or before you guys become
exclusive or whatever you have to vet
and this is what we're saying on our
live the other day
um
you you there has to be certain things
that you see and attributes you see in a
person that makes them husband material
wife material and if you don't see them
then you don't get to that point where
you're exclusive you just have to be
smart about it if a man decides that
he's going to wife someone that's quote
unquote a slack or not wifey material
right and and that doesn't make sense to
me because how can you not how can you
be a slack and be wifey material you
can't right so so if you can't be wife
if it's right so you were saying there's
a difference between being wife material
and not being a slag yeah yeah yeah
right so so in that same breath can
right let me ask it then can you be a
slack and be wifey material
none of it makes sense
no no so what he said he's saying there
are more standards for men when picking
a wife than just doesn't sleep around a
slag is a British term
so it's not it's not just it's not just
doesn't sleep around equals what because
because I've I've had a girl that came
on the show right and she she had really
low body count but a lot of guys would
overpass her because of her mindset and
so a lot and so and so a lot of a lot of
women think their wife material because
they haven't slept around a lot
but but it's not just about that it's
about the mindset and and what he's
saying is that mindset I don't know you
guys personally but that mindset's toxic
but you know like like because you're
you're older than me you're 30 33. like
to me it's like it's crazy you're you're
prioritizing sex is the most important
thing right now sex is important to me
only because I don't need a man to do
anything in my life for me right now
right
right now but like you have to act with
some sense of urgency you're not getting
younger and so if you're I don't want
more children you might not want more
children you want a husband but yeah do
you want some more sex do you want a
husband can I just ask do you want
I do want a lifelong partner and um and
this is where like I said the vetting
process goes it I have to see certain
attributes within you and likewise you
have to see that within me during our
dating process to see if we're really
compatible in that way yes I do want a
lifelong partner but at the same time I
want someone I can have fun with have
adventures with do this in that with and
whatever I don't want to feel like I'm
going backwards in the sense of
don't get better than your baby daddy
that's the dude you gave everything to
because why would why would a guy pay
more for a lower product it's a worse
product you seem like a nice woman I'm
not I'm don't take this person but but
like like you're older you have kids and
it's like it's you're asking for a
higher price for a worse product no I'm
willing to compromise so he might not
have the heart that I want he might not
have to come back
they might not have the paycheck that I
want right okay but he had he's he's
charismatic he's funny he gives me the
giggles he makes me excited he gives me
certain things and vice versa I also
give that to him in turn I'm willing to
compromise he might have children he
might have one or two baby mothers I'm
not willing to compromise because I
understand that in the marketplace I'm
of lower value in that sense so well
yeah I think it's achievable if I lower
my stand a little bit
this guy doesn't seem real that you're
describing standards
the thing is though when you said like
there's this thing about like a guy and
a girl almost like having a feeling out
process at the beginning and kind of
assessing each other's vibe
I'm not listen I'm not trying to betray
the fellas the male viewership forgive
me but I've got to be honest but here
for honesty right I feel like because
men are
my humble opinion man I think are more
innately in tune with what you want even
if I'm not what you want I know I'm not
really what you want but I know what you
want but as long as I know how to act
like what you want I'll get what I want
because will you know what you want
because we've heard what you want our
whole life TLC No Scrubs
you know that yeah but you see that um
that mindset yeah that mindset comes
from a mindset of a man who regularly
has sex with women right do you
understand that yes my God men that
don't regularly have sex with women and
don't generally know women they don't
know that all they know is themselves
they don't know how to kind of play the
game and get what they want out of a
woman and blah blah blah
say again do you think that's connected
to why then they have less sex because
they don't know how to play the field
and they don't understand yeah because a
lot of men do not know how to play the
game to get sex a lot of men want sex
from women right but don't know how to
play the game a lot of you've got to
learn women you've got a lot sometimes
you've got a women say they don't want
Liars they won't lie yeah yeah because
like men because if men told women the
truth yeah they wouldn't like men they
really won't like it women want Liars
there's a lot of there's a lot of men
lie to me baby yeah
some of the most unsuccessful men in
love are might be the ones who listen
the most to what the woman in their life
claims to want certain times you can be
what a woman claims to want and then
turn out you're absolutely not what she
wants to do so should women go for the
men that they friend zone no we're not
women are sick yeah you've got great
you've got great guys in the friend zone
yeah your friend zones where it went
wrong is what you should be checking
that's what you should be checking
because those are the men with the with
the with the actual interior credentials
that probably would have worked for you
but maybe their exterior wasn't that's
right
surely why they're in a frenzel surely
the ocean's a bit deeper though don't
you think like because this this is an
issue for most modern women now this
level of like narcissism and delusion
that everyone's a 10 out of 10 and needs
the top guy and you know no matter what
I don't know how old I am I still
deserve this 10 out of 10 guy with a six
foot sorry yeah surely just telling
these women hey just date your friend
zone guy make the decision that makes
sense is not going to be the solution
because these aren't irrational people
that they're not rational people so
surely the problem is a bit deeper and
the problem is the average guys are
popping now and it makes them mad makes
them angry because you know the above
average guys yeah there's a lot of women
who some not all there's a portion of
women who they can look back in their
past and reminisce about when they had
so and so they might feel like in their
younger years you know what I might
still be able to catch and keep a man
like so-and-so whereas nowadays it's
more like a memorial thing like I
remember when I was when me and so and
so dated I remember that I don't get mad
like that now but and you know what's
happened to the average guy culture
average guys leveled up thank you yeah
thank you and and the woman yeah who was
the the one that everybody wanted when
they were younger she's kind of looking
kind of a little bit weird but the New
Seasons
That's one solution but I I think I
think one thing we need to fix is the
media because I think there was a point
in my life while I was trying to figure
out women yeah I thought you know I
think the best way to do this is to just
read some romance books and the level of
[ __ ] I read I still have to like oh no
wash my brains nobody is to read it
because Jordan Peterson already had a
lecture on this he said if you read
women's romance novels women have very
um uh um very uh they have archetypes
that they like werewolf and it's so
crazy like it was werewolf uh what was
it surgeon a pirate and this is a
mysterious other guy women get they get
turned on but these romance novels sell
in the millions so yeah read women's
room
as many of you know I was just banned on
tank talk and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible